By bringing the entire Marvel Cinematic Universe
together to face off against a universe-threatening
bad guy, Marvel appears poised to make all
the money in the world when Avengers: Infinity
War hits theaters.
The film looks huge, and everything we’ve
see so far has fans more than eager to see
more. But why exactly should this one knock
our socks off? From the ante-upping villain,
to fundamental changes in store for core Marvel
heroes, here's why we think Infinity War will
blow us all away.
The next Darth Vader?
The entire MCU has been framed around the
idea that an insanely powerful villain by
the name of Thanos has been pulling the strings
behind most of the universe's problems. He’s
popped up in The Avengers and Guardians of
the Galaxy to cause trouble, sending lackeys
ahead of him in an effort to acquire the ultra-powerful
Infinity Stones.
After years of setting him up, Infinity War
will finally place Thanos front and center,
and co-director Joe Russo has said that he’s
"hoping to make a Darth Vader for a new generation."
With another Avengers sequel arriving in just
one year, he might remain a key player in
the MCU even after the dust settles from Infinity
War.
Asgard go boom
The first two installments of the Thor franchise
were arguably some of the weakest in Marvel's
lineup, but all that changed in 2017. Under
director Taika Waititi, Thor: Ragnarok reinvigorated
the series and added a sense of humor the
mainstream MCU never knew it was missing.
“Shoo off, ghost!”
It also featured some of the biggest character
growth yet for Chris Hemsworth's Thor. He
lost his hammer, his father, his eye, and
when Asgard was destroyed, his home.
Despite the losses, Thor emerged a stronger
hero. Co-director Anthony Russo has said he
feels Thor might be the most interesting character
heading into Infinity War after his "past
has been torn away from him." The one-eyed
Thor will have to overcome his losses in Ragnarok,
and find a new hammer, to take on the most
dangerous villain the heroes have ever faced.
U Nomad, bro?
One of the biggest changes for the MCU over
the past few years is that when we pick up
the action in Infinity War, Captain America
might not even be Captain America anymore.
The first glimpses we've gotten of Steve Rogers
show him sporting a beard and no shield — and
in his most recent autograph signings, Cap
actor Chris Evans has been using the name
"Nomad" — a moniker Rogers took up in the
comics after becoming disillusioned with his
role as Captain America. There’s no word
on whether the big-screen version will follow
the same track, but Captain America: Civil
War pulled the Avengers apart — it'll be
interesting to see whether Infinity War can
bring them back together.
I am teenage Groot
There's no denying the role Groot has played
in the success of the Guardians' films, and
bringing him over to a mainline Avengers film
as a moody tree teen adds yet another bit
of geeky goodness to Infinity War. Motion
capture artist Terry Notary, who provided
the movements for Groot, said the character
will be "coming of age" in Infinity War, which
should make for one interesting subplot to
go along with all the world-ending stakes.
Iron...Spider?
Fans got a brief peek at a new Spider-Man
suit at the end of Spider-Man: Homecoming,
and the trailers for Infinity War show Peter
Parker will definitely be taking advantage
of the upgrade when Thanos strikes. If you
pay attention to the LEGO toy tie-ins for
the film, though, we might just be seeing
another new design for Spidey: the Iron Spider
suit that Tony Stark made for Peter in the
comics. What better place to pull it out than
in Marvel's biggest movie ever?
Wakanda takes center stage
Black Panther blew the roof off the box office
and made T’Challa an instant icon for superhero
fans. Luckily, they won’t have to wait to
see a lot more of the world of Wakanda.
Every trailer and teaser for Infinity War
has made it abundantly clear that Black Panther
and Wakanda are going to be a huge factor.
They’re on full display, with plenty of
interactions between T’Challa and Steve
Rogers.
“And get this man a shield.”
Giant-Size Marvel
As if it weren't already obvious, Infinity
War is poised to be Marvel's biggest movie
to date. It's bringing A-list stars and key
supporting players from every solo Marvel
franchise, loading the film with everyone
fans have come to know and love over a decade
of the MCU. But it doesn’t just combine
the Guardians of the Galaxy and the Avengers
into the same storyline. It brings them into
one single fight.
Anthony Mackie, who plays Falcon, has said
it'll feature a scene with a mind-boggling
40 heroes onscreen at the same time, making
the massive brawl in Captain America; Civil
War look like a a tussle on the playground
by comparison. Marvel has flexed its blockbuster
muscle time and again over the last decade,
but Infinity War looks like it's really ready
to throw down the gauntlet — no pun intended.
End of an era?
With Infinity War putting a cap on the first
ten years of the Marvel Cinematic Universe,
it's hard not to start looking ahead at what
Disney's pending purchase of Fox could mean
for the future. If everything pans out, Marvel
may look to reacquire the rights to their
other two biggest teams: the Fantastic Four
and the X-Men.
It stands to reason those characters will
eventually be folded into the MCU in the same
way that Spider-Man was brought in after Marvel
Studios cut a deal with Sony. Fans hoping
for a sneak peek in Infinity War will likely
be disappointed, though. Marvel Studios head
honcho Kevin Feige has made clear any potential
purchase will not impact the studio's current
slate of productions lined up through 2019
— which include both Infinity War and its
untitled sequel. That slow roll is probably
a good thing, considering this movie is already
looking to juggle dozens and dozens of characters
as it stands.
Thanks for watching! Click the Looper icon
to subscribe to our YouTube channel. Plus
check out all this cool stuff we know you'll
love, too!